uh the nice wars we are about to play
some
games against magnus let's try to have
fun as a guy's in brilliant shape
and yeah he managed to beat our team of
yesterday
without a single so let's try to you
know do in at least one game and yeah
there we go one d4
and stars
okay
yeah so first we make sure the bishop is
on z2 and then we
play a game
and give the check okay let's enable
and bishop g2 and castles
yeah he plays b6 i think we've played
this we played this like a billion of
times
in the magnet stores obviously i'm not
going to
[Music]
uh to spoil any real ideas for this uh
pointless match
but at the same time after b6 you can
just play
yeah you can just play normal moves and
you're always
very very slightly better
okay
where is 94 what is the move here
[Music]
i don't know maybe queen c2 is fine so
sometimes we'll just take and go 95.
yeah he plays a 5.
he likes this kind of a position okay
so now
now i don't know what to do i must say
okay first let's play rook c1 to you
know
create a threat of some cgd queen take
c7 and some lines
if he plays rook s8 i think it's a
decent
decent inclusion for us
yeah he's thinking for some reason i
don't know why but that's what strong
players do sometimes
yeah rooks say it happens
maybe i can just play h3 then after
bishop e7 or d6 i go b4 simply
and he goes to d6 okay let's play b4
now c5 followed by c6 is a thread
if he goes c5 i think it is always a
relief yeah he plays c6
no relief
um
so maybe we just uh maybe we just take
and
try to play f3 one day i don't know this
is sharp
okay let's try to take simply
goes dx and i thought we can play knight
t5
okay let's go 95
now c5 looks reasonable maybe that's why
i had to
include c4 c5 myself but on the other
hand after c5
i will probably some point we'll take on
d7 take on c5 with the d pawn and play
b5
uh he plays knight f6 okay
rook d1 looks normal to me
c5 looks normal as well
i don't know what is the right way to
play this to be honest
okay maybe we just go c5
takes takes and then we prepare f3
somehow
he probably wants to play bishop a6 when
a4 makes sense in that regard
rook f2 d1 can never be too bad as well
so queen a4 he probably wants to play a5
and then takes b5
if we go queen b's i don't know
we should just play something probably
[Music]
and play it quickly okay let's play
rook after d1 it should not be
dramatically bad anyway
yeah bishop a6 was his idea indeed
no and maybe we are getting all played a
little
[Music]
or maybe not
i don't know what i'm doing exactly but
i also don't want to
to lose some time yeah queen is seven
can we play f3 here f3 would be a nice
thing to you know to get
okay let's try
i don't think c5 works if he takes we
probably take with a bishop
okay
then we'll probably get e4 yeah he puts
a four this makes sense
trying to attack somehow
um yeah this
is sort of unpleasant
should i play g4
it's hard to tell okay let's play g4
and then maybe king each one okay he has
this greenish four idea but it's not yet
it's not yet made
ghost93 simply take stakes
now we can attack this pawn somehow
maybe queen g5
and we probably keep it simple and go to
c3 or something
he plays c5 okay takes
this allows rook d6 i don't know if we
need it okay let's
let's try this
i think the the way he played is not uh
it's not brilliant white is better now
but it's going to be time trouble anyway
but at least we sort of managed to
outplay him a little
which is already kind of winning a side
point okay takes
now maybe rook v6 or rugby one maybe it
will b6 or queen v6
even
queen g5
so he wants to play c3
which will sleep laundered
okay takes and rook c6 doesn't work
starts with a check okay king g2 rook c6
so what's wrong with that
h5 okay let's see queen c4
yeah queen c4 was extremely stupid
obviously
yeah now i have to take and look for
some queen h5
yeah i think we win this and rook takes
c1
okay at least we managed to win one game
and b75
okay
not that yeah